This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
In this 6 Minute English, we're talking about music.
What sort of music do you like listening to, Sam?
Well, I wouldn't say I have one specific type.
My taste in songs is more eclectic.
A word that describes taste, which includes a wide variety of styles.
Well, in this programme, we're talking all about grime,
a style of music which originated in London,
specifically in the Tower Blocks of East and Southeast London.
Yes, the artist's predominantly young black men
and often cite the decaying tower blocks they grew up in
as an inspiration for the urban style of music.
Well, before we continue talking about grime music,
I have a question for you, Sam.
Storm Z is one of the most famous grime artists.
But what is his real name? Is it A?
Michael Amari, B? Martin O'Whosu, or C?
Marvin Apaya.
I think I might know this one.
I'll say A. Michael Amari.
We can find out if you're right at the end of this programme.
For many people, knowing the origin of a type of music
helps them to understand more about the style and lyrics.
Here's writer Jude Jorson, talking with BBC journalist Andrew Mar,
about his experience growing up on a station
Southeast London on the BBC Radio 4 programme, Start the Week.
Yes, I live like an estate.
This is an annually near crystal palace.
And for me, growing up, the experience was like literally
you can only see the different cultures and peoples
that live within this estate.
And it was around the age of about seven or eight.
That's when things for me and my particular state started to get a bit more contentious
with the other people that are moving in.
Kids are coming off age, becoming more free and venturing out and around the estate.
And please, kind of harassing.
But you've got different cultures knocking into each other
and then please knock into everybody else.
Yeah.
So Jude Jorson describes his upbringing.
He used the word contentious, likely to cause or create an argument
to describe life on the estate.
Yes, and he said the kids were coming of age,
meaning transitioning from a child to an adult.
In his interview, he goes on to say how a teacher gave him the advice
that if he ever got stabbed, not to remove the knife as he would bleed to death.
He says that at the age of 14 when he was told that he felt grateful
and that the teacher was looking out for him.
But in hindsight, questions why a teenager should receive that information.
What this does is give us an insight into life and the background that led to some people,
like Stormzy, creating grime music.
He says that it started off in the bedrooms and basements of tower blocks and homes
in these areas of London, with many artists work being broadcast on pirate radio
stations.
That said, for some people, this type of music represents something different.
There are some who think the hard-hitting lyrics and strong beats glorify violence.
They see it as an aggressive and violent form of music.
However, Jude Jorson, speaking with Andrew Mar on the BBC Radio 4 program start the week,
has a different interpretation of what grime music is all about.
I describe grime as like a soulful shell.
There's a necessity in literally getting all of this content out of yourself.
And one of the most predominant grime artists,
Wiley was basically the first person that created this sound.
It's like 140 beats per minute because that's such a raw tune.
But the chorus literally chants like there are lots of signs in life,
some that you may not realise.
And for me, I was listening to that as like an 11-12 year old and is very existential.
He used the word predominant, which describes the strongest or most important thing,
to describe the artist, Wiley.
That's who Jude Jorson says was the first person to create the grime sound.
He also used the verb chants, sings repeatedly over and over,
to talk about the chorus from one of Wiley's songs.
And he described the experience of listening to it as being existential,
relating to human existence.
Which inspires me to go and listen to some grime music after today's show.
But before we do, I ask you a question about the real name of the grime artist Stormzy.
You did and being a fan of many different music styles, I think I know this one.
I said, A, Michael Amari.
You really do know your music, Sam. You are right.
In fact, his full name is Michael Ebenezer Quadro Amari Urujo, Jr.
I think I'll have to make the next question much harder for you.
So before we leave today, let's recap the vocabulary, starting with eclectic.
A word which describes taste, which includes a wide variety of styles.
Contentious means creating or causing arguments.
We also have coming of age transitioning from child to adult.
Predominant refers to something that is the strongest or most important.
Chance is a verb which means sing or repeat the same thing over and over again.
An existential means relating to human existence.
Well, we certainly learned a lot about grime music and its origin.
There are lots more six-minute English programs to enjoy on our website at bbclearningenglish.com.
Thanks for listening and goodbye.